now the message from experts tonight
though keep those gatherings small as
the country is still trying to curb the
spread of covet 19.
sasha loftus joining us now live tonight
to share what doctors and those
celebrating safely are saying
sasha denise and brian the message here
is nothing new
avoid those large gatherings at your
home to slow the spread of covid19
but experts i spoke with say it's more
important now than ever
as we're just seeing those cases drop
after the holidays
they say they really don't want to see a
surge again
the countdown is on to super bowl 55.
we've had to like disappoint a lot of
people no not this year
brady's going for the big ball we're all
looking forward to the big game
but kovit 19 is forcing many including
lisa and tashaumba green
to switch up their celebrations we
wanted to make sure that we
were together but at the same time that
as a group we probably shouldn't be
around each other the cdc is urging
others to follow suit
suggesting virtual gatherings rather
than in-person parties this sunday
if history is any teacher
look at thanksgiving look at christmas
new year's dr
jonathan bogtari of e-7 health says if
las vegas don't stay home
our positivity rate which has decreased
to 16.3 percent
could jump right back up again just like
it did after the holidays
you could actually plot a curve two
three weeks after
all of those events go back to nevada's
numbers you can
see it i mean it's crystal clear it may
seem tough to pass on something yet
again
but the greens believe it's more
important now than ever
it's not worth it just for that one day
or that one celebration
they're asking everyone to consider the
consequences
and just follow the rules
now if you do choose to gather this
sunday experts say the cdc says
keep those gatherings very small
socially distanced
outdoors and of course wear masks if you
do have guests inside dr bhaktari says
it would help to
crack a door or crack a window to
increase that ventilation
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now